The word solidarity appears 16 times in the
Treaties
Our European budget is living proof of financial
solidarity.
The euro is an expression of solidarity.
Our development policy is a strong external
sign of solidarity.
And when it comes to managing the refugee
crisis, we have started to see solidarity.
I am convinced much more solidarity is needed.
But I also know that solidarity must be
voluntary. It must come from the heart.
It cannot be forced. It cannot be imposed.
I am urging the Slovak Presidency to bridge the divergencies and differences between those who are
reluctant to integrate refugees in their societies and those who are convinced, as I am, that the fair share
in the relocation and resettlement is of the essence.
What I am asking is strong and immediate action both from Greece and the European Union
to protect what we call in French les enfants non accompagnés.
Without protection of these children, the European Union is betraying its historic values.
In the
same spirit, the Commission is proposing today
to set up a European Solidarity Corps.
Young people across the EU will be able to
volunteer their help where it is needed most,
to respond to crisis situations, like the
refugee crisis or the recent earthquakes in Italy.